Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Two: Denmark's sights, starting with Jutland.
A large number of Danish and foreign tourists choose each year to holiday in Denmark.
According to Denmark's national tourism organisation, VisitDenmark, 68 million overnight stays were registered in 2025 at hotels, hostels, holiday centres, campsites and in holiday homes in Denmark.
Of these, Danes accounted for 31 million, while Germany was clearly the biggest foreign market with 22 million overnight stays.
By far most overnight stays take place in the coastal areas, where tourists come not least to experience Danish nature.
Especially the Vesterhavet, the North Sea, attracts many tourists.
The Danish and foreign tourists in Denmark spent a total of 168 billion kroner in 2024.
Many tourists also choose to see and experience a number of Denmark's sights, including the seven sites that are on UNESCO's World Heritage List.
UNESCO is the UN's organisation for education, culture, communication and science.
They can, for example, be buildings or natural areas that are of particular great importance for the whole world.
This section is about some of Denmark's most important sights.
First, Jutland.
Skagen.
Skagens Gren is Denmark's northernmost point.
Here the two seas, Skagerrak and Kattegat, meet.
That means you can stand with one foot in each sea and see the waves clash together.
In 1795, the church south of the town had to be closed because it was buried by all the sand that blew in over it.
All that is left is the tower of "the Buried Church", Den tilsandede Kirke, as a monument to nature's enormous forces.
In the period of about 1875 to 1910, Skagen was in the summer an international meeting place for painters, kunstmalere, called the Skagen Painters, Skagensmalerne, such as Anna Ancher, Michael Ancher and P.S.
Krøyer.
They searched for new motifs, and they found them in Skagen in the form of the fishermen and their hard life, as well as the special light reflected by the light beaches and the sea on both sides.
Most of the Skagen Painters' main works can be seen at Skagens Museum.
Tirpitz and the Atlantic Wall.
At Blåvand near Esbjerg in West Jutland, the Nazi occupying power began in 1944 to build Batterie Vogelnest, "Battery Bird's Nest", also called Tirpitz, with two enormous gun bunkers.
They were to be part of the gigantic defence work the Atlantic Wall, Atlantvolden, which the Germans wanted to build along the whole European Atlantic coast.
Denmark's location by the North Sea made the country a part of this defence work against a possible Allied invasion.
Therefore, from 1942, many bunkers were built and landmines laid along the whole of Jutland's west coast, Jyllands vestkyst.
The bunkers are not on Sjælland's east coast and not on Lolland's south coast.
Tirpitz was to have defended the approach to the west coast's only larger town, Esbjerg, with artillery that could shoot 55 kilometres.
But the bunker never managed to be finished before Denmark's liberation in May 1945.
After the war, Danish engineer troops tried without success to blow it away.
Therefore it and many other German bunkers still stand as a reminder of the occupation, in the west coast's magnificent dune landscape.
Tirpitz opened as a museum in 2017.
A tunnel connects the concrete in the new architecture with the old gun bunker with its more than three-metre-thick walls of reinforced concrete.
Den Gamle By.
Parts of the Market Town Museum, Købstadsmuseet, in Aarhus, called Den Gamle By, "The Old Town", are a model of a small Danish town as it could have looked in the 1800s.
It consists of about 75 houses that have been rebuilt from all over Denmark.
The rebuilt houses are from the period 1550 to 1900, and the museum has continuously expanded with three new neighbourhoods with houses and shops from the most recent 100 years.
There are thus also parts of Den Gamle By that show how a Danish town looked from 1927 to 2014.
Moesgaard Museum.
The spectacular museum building from 2014, designed by Henning Larsen's architecture studio in cooperation with Kristine Jensen's studio, lies a little south of Aarhus.
The museum's exhibitions contain especially finds from Denmark's prehistory, that is the Stone Age, Bronze Age and Iron Age, as well as from the Viking Age.
Among other things, you find Grauballe Man, who is the world's best preserved bog body.
About 290 before Christ, in the Iron Age, his throat was cut.
The reason the body is so well preserved is the chemical processes in the bog in East Jutland where he was laid.
When he was killed, he was 34 years old, and he was probably sacrificed to a god who was believed to live in the depths of the bog.
The Wadden Sea, Vadehavet.
The Wadden Sea, which follows the coast from northern Holland across Germany and up to Blåvandshuk in south-western Jutland, is 500 kilometres long.
It is the world's largest continuous wadden sea landscape and one of the ten most important wetlands in the whole world.
Twice a day the tide pumps water in, so it becomes high tide, and out, so it becomes low tide, of the Wadden Sea.
This provides nourishment in the form of algae and plankton for an incredible amount of fish, mussels, worms and snails, which in turn is food for the larger animals in the food chain such as birds.
For example there can be up to 60,000 snails per square metre.
And the Wadden Sea therefore functions every spring and autumn as a giant restaurant for 10 to 12 million migratory birds.
Including several threatened species that stop here on their long journey from south to north in spring and north to south in autumn.
Among the biggest experiences at the Wadden Sea is the phenomenon "Black Sun", Sort Sol, when hundreds of thousands of starlings settle down for the night and perform a fascinating bird ballet.
The Wadden Sea Centre southwest of Ribe, designed by the Danish architect Dorte Mandrup, tells the story of the Wadden Sea.
Ribe.
Ribe arose as a market and trading place at the beginning of the 700s and is thereby the oldest town in Denmark.
Among the many traders from Europe were also missionaries who tried to convert the Danish population to Christianity.
In 855, about 100 years before Harald Blåtand as the first Danish king had himself baptised as a Christian, the German missionary Ansgar built a church in Ribe.
The town today has a particularly well-preserved town centre from the Middle Ages with cobbled streets and half-timbered houses.
Most central, however, is Ribe Cathedral, Ribe Domkirke, from the 1000s, 1100s and 1300s, which contains some very large, colourful modern glass mosaics and wall paintings with stories from the Bible.
They are made by the Danish artist Carl-Henning Pedersen in the period 1982 to 87.
Rold Skov and Rebild Bakker.
Rold Skov is Denmark's second largest forest after Grib Skov in North Zealand.
Originally the forest consisted primarily of beech trees, but so many spruce and pine trees have been planted that today it is mostly coniferous forest.
Rebild Bakker, Rebild Hills, is a landscape with heath and stunted beech trees.
Part of the area was in 1912 bought by Danish-Americans.
Here you find the festival ground where every year a Danish-American celebration of the USA's Independence Day, the fourth of July, is held.
In Museum Rebild you can also learn about the more than 300,000 Danes who emigrated to the USA, especially in the years 1868 to 1914.
Rebild Bakker and Rold Skov are Northern Europe's largest area of natural springs of water.
The rainwater seeps down through the ground to the chalk of the subsoil.
Here the water is cleaned until it flows up to the surface again, when at some point it is pressed up again to the ground surface by the weight of the hills.
The chalk in the subsoil works like a sponge and stores the water, so it constantly has a temperature of seven to eight degrees, regardless of the season.
Among the many springs, Ravnkilde can be mentioned, whose pure water tastes wonderful.
Here is your recap for Episode Two.
In 2025 there were 68 million overnight stays in Denmark: 31 million by Danes, and 22 million by Germans, the biggest foreign market.
Tourists spent 168 billion kroner in 2024.
There are seven UNESCO World Heritage Sites.
Skagens Gren is Denmark's northernmost point, where Skagerrak and Kattegat meet; the Skagen Painters were there from about 1875 to 1910.
From 1942 the Germans built bunkers along Jutland's west coast; Tirpitz at Blåvand began in 1944 and opened as a museum in 2017.
Den Gamle By in Aarhus has about 75 houses.
Moesgaard Museum, from 2014, has Grauballe Man, the world's best preserved bog body, from about 290 before Christ.
The Wadden Sea is 500 kilometres long, with 10 to 12 million migratory birds, and Black Sun is the starling flocks.
Ribe is Denmark's oldest town, from the early 700s, with Ansgar's church from 855.
Rold Skov is Denmark's second largest forest after Grib Skov; Rebild Bakker was bought by Danish-Americans in 1912, and the fourth of July is celebrated there.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What are Anna Ancher and Michael Ancher especially known for?
Option A: They were composers.
Option B: They were film directors.
Option C: They were painters.
[DA] Hvad er Anna Ancher og Michael Ancher særligt kendt for?  A: De var komponister  |  B: De var filminstruktører  |  C: De var kunstmalere
The answer is C: They were painters.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: De var kunstmalere
Question 2.
What is P.S.
Krøyer, 1851 to 1909, especially known for?
Option A: He was an author.
Option B: He was a composer.
Option C: He was a painter.
[DA] Hvad er P.S. Krøyer (1851-1909) særlig kendt for?  A: Han var forfatter  |  B: Han var komponist  |  C: Han var kunstmaler
The answer is C: He was a painter.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Han var kunstmaler
Question 3.
In which town in Jutland did Anna Ancher and Michael Ancher paint especially many of their pictures at the end of the 1800s?
Option A: Silkeborg.
Option B: Sønderborg.
Option C: Skagen.
[DA] Ved hvilken by i Jylland malede Anna Ancher og Michael Ancher særligt mange af deres billeder i slutningen af 1800-tallet?  A: Silkeborg  |  B: Sønderborg  |  C: Skagen
The answer is C: Skagen.
It appeared in the November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Skagen
Question 4.
Along which coast in Denmark are there especially many bunkers that the Germans had built during the Second World War?
Option A: Lolland's south coast.
Option B: Zealand's east coast.
Option C: Jutland's west coast.
[DA] Langs hvilken kyst i Danmark ligger der særligt mange bunkere, som tyskerne fik bygget under 2. Verdenskrig?  A: Lollands sydkyst  |  B: Sjællands østkyst  |  C: Jyllands vestkyst
The answer is C: Jutland's west coast.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Jyllands vestkyst
Question 5.
What is the oldest town in Denmark called?
Option A: Ribe.
Option B: Esbjerg.
Option C: Frederikshavn.
[DA] Hvad hedder den ældste by i Danmark?  A: Ribe  |  B: Esbjerg  |  C: Frederikshavn
The answer is A: Ribe.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ribe
Question 6.
In which Danish city can you visit, among other things, Den Gamle By and the art museum ARoS?
Option A: Helsingør.
Option B: Odense.
Option C: Aarhus.
[DA] I hvilken dansk by kan man blandt andet besøge Den Gamle By og kunstmuseet ARoS?  A: Helsingør  |  B: Odense  |  C: Aarhus
The answer is C: Aarhus.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Aarhus
That's the end of this part.
Well done.